grosse émotion dans le monde de la haute
couture l'annoncé du départ imminent
d'yves saint laurent
ce créateur de génie a choisi le 40e
anniversaire de la fondation de sa
maison pour tirer sa révérence l'âme
sensible et prise de brut et n'aura
peut-être pas résisté à la forte
pression du monde des affaires à 65 ans
yves saint laurent ne jette toutefois
pas l'eponge il prend plutôt du recul
sabine gorny dont quelques vues sans
doute pour la dernière fois il viendra
saluer avec cet éternel sourire inquiet
comme encore étonné de son succès la fin
d'un règne absolu sur la mode depuis
plus de 40 ans depuis ce 30 janvier 58
lui succédant à christian dior à 21 ans
ce jeune homme surdoué venu d'oran
devient le plus jeune couturier du monde
a ri s'extasie paris cryogénie de son
nouveau petit prince de la mode
quatre ans plus tard avec l'aide de
pierre bergé le pygmalion l'ami de
toujours
il ouvre sa propre maison de couture
avec une obsession habillé l'époque je
crois que c'est la plus importante chez
un couturier c'est d'avoir un style qui
soit bien à lui et qui se reconnaissent
un style reconnaissable entre mille
élégantissime du noir
il va faire une vraie couleur il invente
la garde-robe de la femme moderne
l'imposent le caban la saharienne et
surtout le tailleur pantalon et le
smoking reconduit depuis dans chacune de
ses collections
une mini révolution jusqu'en 68 le
pantalon et est transcrit des
garde-robes chic à sa manière sans
laurent accompagné de la libération de
neuf concessionnels elles avaient libéré
les femmes commencer et moi je pense que
ça ne rend leur a donné le pouvoir
un esprit libre saint laurent le premier
a défilé pour la fête de l'humanité le
premier à poser nue pour son parfum au
bout de ce scandale le premier à offrir
à deux milliards de téléspectateurs le
plus grand défilé des prospectives du
monde
le premier à être entré de son vivant au
musée auprès des peintres qu'il a dans
sa mode si souvent célébrer l'art qui
lui seul peut consoler cette âme
tourmentée par répondre désir des femmes
de maintenir la maison à son premier
rang de de créer quoi la création c'est
la douleur un nouveau yves mathieu saint
laurent avait juré qu'il aurait son nom
gravé en lettres de feu sur les champs
elysées de ce lieu en un demi-siècle de
travail acharné il a su bâtir un empire
de faire de la couture expression de
laisser l'air et de la légèreté un art
majeur